hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and just
checking in on you
all right right out of the gate you got
to be like Bill why are you so [ __ ]
subdued where's that energy that I need
to get my Thursday well I live my best
life going well it's like 5:30 in the
[ __ ] morning right so maybe you
thinking hey Bill
why are you up so early maybe you're not
thinking that maybe I'm so [ __ ]
self-involved that I think that you give
a [ __ ] what I'm doing I got some acting
work so tough actin tinactin I got some
acting work ape and the [ __ ] always
starts really early I can't tell you
what I'm doing I can't tell you I always
tell you the role that I'm playing a cop
you know because what else am I going to
play all right cop firemen confused
ginger
I'm very limited so it's just a quickie
couple of day thing here that I've been
doing spread out over a couple of weeks
or whatever you know yesterday was the
first day you know it was all action
chasing this [ __ ] guy down this
goddamn alley they had me running like
[ __ ] TJ hook you guys ever watched TJ
Hooker I don't think in the history of
television there's ever been a [ __ ]
actor of a certain age that ran more
that ran further distances in an episode
of television he has that record and an
overall in the series than William
Shatner when he was on TJ Hooker they
used to have this poor guy and he was
like in his 50s I think when he did TJ
Hooker right they used to have this guy
start like 50 yards away I know I've
talked about this before and they would
show him and he would have to run all
the way to the camera and just when you
thought that was done then they did the
reverse shot and he ran another 50 yards
just haulin ass in cop shoes with that
[ __ ] utility belt on I always
respected
man for that not when I was younger I
just thought he was the man and then I
you know got into my 30s and I'd still
watch TJ Hooker I was like I can't even
run like that now in my thirties well
yesterday at 51 they had me [ __ ]
doing that running probably 1/8 what
William Shatner did no Billy freckles
went right home he got into a bath of
epsom salt and I feel like a million
dollars
come on it and I feel like a million
bucks in my little room here hey what's
going on I'm doing my podcast here those
are the sides yeah these are the sides
all right cool
all right thank you okay
well just make up no here right all
right the extra make up paint my head
all right I guess I'll have to do this
some [ __ ] sports here so the podcast
as you know by the time you're listening
to it it's obviously a little bit late
so uh all right that's it Oh freckles
hey you know what I watched I'm going to
talk about when I get back I watched on
Netflix ever he's telling me about this
documentary like dude you got to go see
you got to watch game changes all right
now game changes just to let you know
it's about game-changing athletes in
their respective sports and it's about
changing your diet so this is yet
another thing claiming you know the
vegan you know whatever way is ready I
read here a bunch of guys let's go give
me a [ __ ] break
you gonna be on that ferry diet eat and
sell it's just just watch it see what
you think I don't [ __ ] know I have no
idea but they're trying to claim these
people are trying to claim that uh that
as far as you know they say you know how
my whole life I said you know if you
want a complete protein you know you got
a need you gotta eat an animal
something has to die if you want a
complete protein all right if you're me
that's a cow or a chicken if you're
Jeffrey Dahmer it's some sort of street
kid all right now everybody gets their
protein from a different place but this
thing is trying to claim
that animals are just the [ __ ]
middleman how these cops put their
[ __ ] stupid-ass boots on every
goddamn day no one there and there's
such a bad mood
[ __ ] slapping around housewives for
running a red light anyway so they're
trying to claim that you know all your
eating is that the animal is the
middleman that the animal got its
protein from the plants and [ __ ] that it
was eating I don't [ __ ] know so I
watched this [ __ ] and I'm seeing all
these absolutely shredded jacked people
I'm like wow man these people eat
vegetarian Wow when they showing what
happens to your blood and all that stuff
so I watched this whole [ __ ] thing
and in the end what do I do I gotta
cross check it right so I [ __ ] go on
the internet and what you know second I
bring it up all these doctors here's
what that documentary missed it's like
you know what go [ __ ] yourself okay
I just hope in my lifetime I know is an
egg good for me or is it bad for me cuz
when I was a kid it was good then it
became bad then he had to eat the
[ __ ] egg whites right then it became
good again and now it's becoming bad
again and then they're started like I
think all these [ __ ] food [ __ ] out
there whatever the [ __ ] they're selling
they're telling you that that's what the
[ __ ] you want to eat and then they [ __ ]
all over something else and the whole
time I'm watching this trying to figure
out what the diet is I just hear my
mother's voice screaming over the
argument as she always does at home
tries to be nuts but I know she's right
all right there's the first six minutes
I got to go [ __ ] put on a utility
belt and run like William Shatner after
a purple alright bye alright I'm back
and just like that it's I don't know
about eight hours later maybe seven and
a half hours later I shoot
Oh Billy freckles easy today no running
no running today for freckles a little
interrogation room I guess we caught the
perp yesterday and that goes back and
forth it goes back and forth
a procedural show anyway so that's it a
tie was done another eight to go you
know four hours sleep and then I got my
last day on this [ __ ] thing that's
how it works that's how it works all
right for all you kiddos out there
well you kiddos out there dreaming dream
and it gettin act and work that's how it
works
sixteen fourteen six twelve fourteen
sixteen something like that one of those
one of those even numbers each day and
then you know and you go home and you
come back and then you do it again and
you're like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
and then you just do it and then it's
over then you kind of sad like I was
kind of you know good and all those
people the whole [ __ ] thing ends I'll
tell you what's gonna end this Sunday
two things are gonna end okay the NFL
football season and the hopes and dreams
of the fans of your who's he going with
Kansas City Chiefs I don't think you
guys got a shot in hell do it on Sunday
I just don't I think that defense is
gonna shut you the [ __ ] down and then
their offense will eventually wear you
down I think that that's what's gonna
happen you know Garoppolo showed signs
of capabilities there then he got hurt I
don't know what's going on but you know
we'll see I think I just I don't think
you guys are gonna [ __ ] win and I've
been betting against you all right then
I'm a Patriots fan so not only in this
one season would you get to see mighty
the Patriots loose you'd also get to see
the Kansas City City shitty Kansas City
Chiefs win and then I would lose a
couple hundred bucks betting against you
I'm not rooting against people of Kansas
City I'll be happy yourself if you you
know if you win the [ __ ] thing I just
don't think you gotta that's all I'm
gonna shut my [ __ ] cell phone off you
love somebody sorry to bug yeah well
then don't you know what the [ __ ] anyway
plow ink I had AI
yeah I just think that uh Sherman's
gonna shut down the side of the field I
don't know how it works I'm not a
defensive coordinator but I would think
that they will put him on whatever his
[ __ ] Kendrick he'll what the hell's
his name
Tyreke Tyree kill whatever the hell his
name is number ten I think he's going to
shut him down and then I think that
lunatic who pretends like he's waving
the flag to get back to the guy wears
too much eyeshadow on the Browns I think
he's gonna be a [ __ ] problem I just
think that defense is gonna be a [ __ ]
problem okay that defense is going to be
a problem in Kansas City's defenses a
problem so then what happens is then San
Francisco's offense stays on the field
all right and they get themselves into a
rhythm both tone don't get down to bump
bump whatever the [ __ ] they gonna
thinking and eventually Kansas City's
gonna break that defense is gonna break
and they're gonna start scoring and
somewhere around I don't know I don't
know I think the beginning of the fourth
quarter they start to run downhill a
little bit but never underestimate the
fact that I I am a firm believer that it
is against the rules for one team to go
up by more than two scores or at the
very least they changed the game enough
where that is practically impossible
with two evenly matched matched up teams
like back in the day I mean there was
like a the Super Bowl was like a blowout
for like a decade in a row all right I'd
say it's let's start with the Steelers
like the Steelers Cowboys 78 was a great
[ __ ] game
all right 79 and then 80 had the Raiders
they played the Eagles that thing you
know rod Martin picked off three both a
[ __ ] thing was Kenny king goes 80
yards on a [ __ ] screen passed the
[ __ ] was over then 81 was the 49ers
first the bengals joe montana bill walsh
first the [ __ ] bengals you know what
that one wasn't too too bad then who
came next l the redskins during the
strike shortened season they played the
Dolphins with like dawn struck and Ron
Woodley that wasn't a good game that was
the John Riggins broke
game open with the sweep Jesus Christ
we're going with my memory here and then
the next year then the [ __ ] Raiders
with less to haze and the stickum
they've kicked the [ __ ] out of the out
of the Redskins and then the 49ers came
back and Fulton Walter returned that
kickoff for a touchdown Dan Marino we
think it's gonna it's over then the
Bears mop the floor with the Patriots
the worst [ __ ] Super Bowl loss of all
time 46 210 I believe and then the
Giants [ __ ] kicked the [ __ ] out of
the Broncos and then the Redskins kicked
the [ __ ] out of the Broncos and then the
49ers kicked the [ __ ] down oh that was a
good one
John Taylor that one came down but all
of those were [ __ ] blowouts and then
the very next year the [ __ ] 49ers
kicked the [ __ ] out of the Broncos like
55 to 10 so the Patriots only held that
awful record for four years and then it
was the bills close game against the
Giants I don't even remember the
Redskins game and then they got [ __ ]
ass raped by the [ __ ] Cowboys two
years in a row and then 49ers went up
against what the charges that game
sucked and then the Cowboys played the
Steelers with Neil Neil O'Donnell that
game sucked then the Patriots first
Green Bay I was at that game and that
game was good until what's his faith was
at desmond howard somebody from michigan
[ __ ] ran the ball back and then that
game sucked then the [ __ ] Broncos
played the falcons and someone on the
Falcons got a hooker and that [ __ ]
them up so that game sucked then what
you have you had the [ __ ] titans
versus the rams that was a great one
then the ravens beat somebody the Giants
that game sucked Patriots beat the Rams
that was an exciting game then the next
year was Tampa first the Raiders some of
the Raiders he thought he already won
the Superbowl started partying he had a
mental breakdown that game sucked bill
you kind of defeating your thing here
that all of a sudden they just became
gay
all right 99 mm those were great games
and then they and no 99 2001 2003 2004
the Steelers won when they played this
[ __ ] Seahawks that one sucked
then the Colts won that one sucked and
then the [ __ ] Giants beat the the
undefeated Patriots that thing went
[ __ ] back and forth that was a great
game there was just like great games I
think somewhere in there somewhere in
the 2000s they changed the [ __ ] rules
and I don't know it just was just so
offense offense friendly
don't touch uh don't look at him after
five yards go easy on the quarterback
all of that [ __ ] horseshit
you know I don't know they tried to
balance it out by trying to [ __ ]
overanalyze what the [ __ ] was a catch or
not but I don't know
anyway plowing ahead here yeah I just
think I think the fournier night is
gonna beat him it's gonna be a close
game but I just I just think the 40 now
is gonna be him because in the end it's
gonna come down the defense and I just
don't think that I just think 49ers
having better defense that's it all
right
I saw many many a great quarterback not
win Super Bowls with high-powered
offenses and three-quarter defenses
alright now I'm an old man and the rules
of the game have changed so maybe now
you can go in there
maybe now offense wins championships
they built maybe now you could shut the
[ __ ] up all right all right up that's
that's my Super Bowl analysis all right
no I have not smoked a cigar if you're
wondering I'm still going I'm two weeks
in and now I don't even think about him
anymore now that's it's just like it's
another person that's all I need about
[ __ ] 2 to 3 weeks and then it's just
like I don't want to [ __ ] do that
again although today when I was sitting
on set waiting I'd be like you know be
great if I was a [ __ ] character actor
in the 70s I could probably smoke inside
this studio next to a child actor
blowin smoke in his face while I [ __ ]
ran lines with him anyway I want to
thank everybody that came out to the the
the eighth annual I said was a ninth
it's the ninth annual since he died nine
years since he died little over nine
years but it was the eighth annual
Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit might have
been our strongest line-up of all time
it just [ __ ] murderers row everybody
[ __ ] martyred all right I want to
thank everybody you know who came down
and did it and Maureen Taran for putting
the whole [ __ ] thing together it was
awesome and then the stand for hooking
us up after for the place to stay it was
just you know great afterparty there it
was just [ __ ] awesome just a great
positive positive night you know all the
proceeds go to his loved ones it's
always such a great thing it's always
good to see everybody too so and it was
also a great mix of comics too I thought
guys that know um men and women that
knew him and then like newer people that
were [ __ ] influenced by him got to
work with them open with forum everybody
was telling for three stories as always
it's just a [ __ ] just a great great
great great time so thank you to
everybody who came out and that's it
we'll do it again next year we're
already up can't believe it all the way
up to nine years
so anyway old man freckles did : thank
you to everybody at the New York City
Center - yeah so yesterday doing this
stupid running down the [ __ ] alley
thing right full speed just [ __ ]
running right and I'm just like there is
no [ __ ] way I'm not gonna get hurt I
just kept stretching and stretching and
stretching and stretching and and you
know back in the day it used to be the
next day I felt it when I woke up in the
morning but this one as I was like
walking off set going to my car I was
like oh no like my legs
the ice my pasty [ __ ] thighs felt
like [ __ ] lead and but I was smart my
old age I went home and drill a bath
piping hot bath and just poured it full
of Epsom salt and just sat in that
[ __ ] for 20 minutes you know letting
the blood flow through the muscles and
all of that [ __ ] and then then I iced my
shoulder and I woke up this morning I
had an early call I felt like a [ __ ]
million bucks epson salt everybody
everybody trying to do you know these
shaker wait [ __ ] things onion
whatever the [ __ ] people do right oh and
also the foam roller big believer in
that but uh yeah I believe in all of
that [ __ ] you know what else I believe
in I believe in stuntmen okay I do that
all the [ __ ] time you know I bet bill
you want to do this you want the you
want you double to do it and I'm always
just like to do
I am reversed Tom Cruise you know he
wants to be glued to the side of a
[ __ ] airplane I don't want to do that
okay I'm also reversed him as far as how
much box-office I bring it Topher come
on bill have a little more faith in
yourself yeah I am a big big big
believer in stuntman anytime hey bill do
you want an op God have the other guy do
it no [ __ ] singer check the scores
[ __ ] going out there hurting myself
pretending to do something why would I
do that there's a job for that it's
called the stuntman you could [ __ ] do
it man I got I got no I got no [ __ ]
business doing that [ __ ] alright when I
was younger thirty years ago 25 years
ago maybe but even then I can't tell you
how many times I've gotten [ __ ] hurt
doing [ __ ] I remember a long time ago
I'm not gonna say the show but we were
doing a sketch and there was a big fight
scene and they didn't even choreograph
this [ __ ] out was the first time I
[ __ ] up my shoulder we [ __ ] did you
know Bay Bay Bay man came in you know I
go down on the ground and then my buddy
was getting knocked out and he was
falling down
and for some dumb reason I just reached
up to catch him with my arm just put it
straight up like that and I don't know
what the [ __ ] I did but it was the back
of my my shoulder blade that's one of
your [ __ ] rote is it rotor cuff a
rotator rotors the break right the thing
that the brake the brake pads squeeze on
rotator cuff retort Horry cup I don't
know what it was but it [ __ ] hurt
like hell but I was young then I went
and this [ __ ] is the first time I've
had a dude give me a massage and I was
uncomfortable for five seconds until he
started doing what he was doing and then
I was so focused on the pain it didn't
matter he was like go and I'm gonna do
this thing that separates the muscle
from the bone I'm like how does it
reattached there that was it that a
little bit of ice and I was good as no
rehab I was in my 20s
[ __ ] rehab rehab in your 20s is maybe
not your 20s but a little bit younger
than that what do you have in your teens
is walking it off I was thinking about
that you know just how funny like how
much I had to stretch just so I could
run and when you're just a kid
you just ran everywhere hey let's go in
the living room
all every kid got up and just ran in
there you've ran everything like your
[ __ ] cardio is ridiculous I don't
think your metabolism slows down as you
get older I just think you stop running
everywhere if you look at these these
kids that's all they [ __ ] do they get
up they run here they run over there you
know one thing that kills me about my
daughter's I I can't like just hang out
and like you know hold her she come on
give me a hug and like it's like half a
second then she like takes off the only
time she lets me hold her is if she
hurts herself or for watching TV and I
don't watch a lot of tea I don't do a
lot of the screen time you know a friend
of our sent us this thing early on about
how these kids today I'll tell you these
kids today when they go to school after
all the screen time that they've watched
iPads tablets whatever you call them
video games and all of that [ __ ] they
are so [ __ ] visually stimulated used
to that that when you go to the
down in a classroom like hi my name is
mrs. mrs. shall of Annie and I will be
teaching it they're just like they just
they can't handle it
they're trying to find a fast-forward
button so I'm trying to avoid my kid
from becoming like me which I probably
watched too much TV with the [ __ ] ad
D and [ __ ] like that I don't know who
knows who the hell knows nobody knows
nobody knows what the right [ __ ]
thing is I told you guys I watched that
game changes right and uh so I've been
trying to eat more of a plant-based diet
or whatever I'll see how I feel you know
I don't know but it's so stupid I'm
doing every [ __ ] vegan does in the
beginning or vegetarian does is you go
okay I'm gonna stop reading meat but I'm
eating meat but I'm not gonna read
anything about nutrition that's [ __ ]
dumb so I think what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna go mainly you know
plant-based I'm so sick of hearing that
or whatever that type of [ __ ] and then
I'll have the occasional you know pork
chop or some [ __ ] I think I'll do that
you know I don't know I'm still a can of
what but I will do this if I was ever to
convert to 100% [ __ ] that vegan [ __ ]
there was no goddamn way I would [ __ ]
give anybody [ __ ] for eating a steak or
something like that you know I mean I'm
big you don't push your [ __ ] on other
[ __ ] people other than your Superbowl
book pick poke pick all right speaking
of this [ __ ] they're gonna call me back
on set here from [ __ ] five seconds Oh
Hollywood bill we get a billion an
acting gig oh really
are you on set you're freckled [ __ ]
alright sorry uh Indo cheeto some reads
here Indochina
how does wearing a suit make you feel
well you know when I wear a suit I feel
you know something I feel like I know
stuff you know what I mean I feel like
I'm ready to waltz into a court room and
get somebody off of death row all right
I just wear sweatpants and a t-shirt
I just feel comfortable in unmotivated
with Indo Chino it's all about you you
get to
choose from hundreds of high-quality
suit fabrics to pick the color pattern
and weight you like best then you choose
all the personal touches this is what I
like including your lining lapel and
your monogram the customizations are all
your choice and there's no extra cost
you know does everything looks the same
you know you buy a shirt you think
you're the only person who bought it
then you see another [ __ ] [ __ ]
wearing look at this what's the odds
somebody's gonna pick the exact same
lining lapel and monogram huh your robot
replacement that's when you know they're
coming through the door all right your
suit is made to your exact measurements
so you end up with a perfect fit for the
shape of your body endo Chino also sells
custom shirts coats and chinos so you
get a full custom wardrobe they have
showrooms across North America Merck
where one of their style guides can take
your measurements and walk you through
the process or you can do it all from
home and Indo Chino calm right now get
an extra $30 off any purchase about $399
or more and Indo Chino comm when
entering birbee you are are at checkout
plus shipping is free that's I n do CH I
n o comm promo code bar for $30 off your
total purchase of $399 or more
high-quality custom suits for an
off-the-rack price oh look who's next
Oh max Oh max you know what living with
chronic pain is the worst it's more than
a feeling of discomfort it can affect
your whole life yeah affects your
disposition and how short you are with
the people you love many of my listeners
probably have some type of pain that has
prevented them from Malak relaxing and
sleeping or stop them from exercising
perhaps it's been ongoing for a few
weeks now or maybe like me for a few
years with my friggin shoulders and
hasn't improved with any of the
treatments they've tried yeah you guys
been listening the podcast I first had
problem with my right shoulder and now I
got a problem I fixed that one
you know rehabbed it now I got my left
shoulder and right here this is what's
been helping me and my left shoulder
heal quicker enter Oh max health if
you're looking to get rid of nagging
muscle and joint pain immediately while
providing long lasting recovery then you
need to try the natural breakthrough
pain relief solution cryofreeze CBD
roll-on developed by Oh max health
this is non-prescription triple action
pain relief roll-on is specially
formulated to block pain receptors
reduce inflammation and improve muscles
and joint flexibility I used this [ __ ]
last night this is this is a personal
testimony I used it last night then if
my shoulder Phil felt amazing in the
morning because I was I was actually
depressed thinking I was like ah [ __ ] I
have to go all the way back to like
resting the shoulder keeping it moving
so it doesn't freeze up and then [ __ ]
go back to rehab but uh fortunately I
lucked out I didn't tweak as much as I
did and then I used the the Oh max here
and I had no pain when I woke up man and
guess what I was in a good mood and I
made my wife laugh even though she was
still sleeping kind of when I woke up so
early
the best part is this is 100% natural
CBD powered remedy works its magic
within ten minutes of application him
relief lasts up to eight hours much
longer than the over-the-counter
products all max health is offering my
listeners 20% off a full bottle of
cryofreeze CBD pain relief roll-on plus
free shipping I'm telling you this [ __ ]
actually works believe it or not and
it's super easy it's a roll-on whatever
it hurts you [ __ ] you roll it on
you're good this discount also applies
towards any products site-wide just go -
Oh max health calm om ax health.com
today and enter the code bir b you are r
that is o max health calm and enter code
ber to get 20% off cryofreeze and
site-wide and go look at the product
reviews they've got 95% five-star
reviews I give him a 5 star also a page
that after page for customers saying
they've tried everything in Oh max
cryofreeze is so good they are now
buying it for their family and their
friends I got a buddy mine's been riding
motorcycles for years his clutch hand
was [ __ ] killing him he [ __ ] rolls
it on he's all good
simply roll it over wherever it hurts
ice out the pain no messy creams or
horrible fragrances like some of the
other products cryofreeze works within
ten minutes of application improving
physical training recovery and
performance so go - Oh max health calm
and entrecote BRR - get 20% off
cryofreeze I'm telling you the product
is the real deal go to OMA X health calm
energy bar to get 20% off site-wide
right there you go the raids aren't done
all right plow ahead here how much what
they gonna call me back [ __ ] soon is
that what's gonna happen here is that
what's gonna happen here all right what
I have almost done my required 30
minutes here all right
so hey I'm I'm picking the [ __ ] the
49ers I think a lot of people have bet
money on the Chiefs that are outside the
Bay Area okay
I think everybody's thinking oh my god
that [ __ ] Patrick mahomes when he
throws it out to Tyreke he'll oh Jesus
Christ
and then Kelsey once you know once he
drops the first three and then finally
catches one and [ __ ] does a Soul
Train dance for 20 minutes and he gets
it going all right there's just gonna be
no stopping I mean everybody wants Andy
Reid the Wilford Brimley of coaches you
know this is his cocoon is he gonna
cannonball into the into a pool of
victory champagne huh
or the 49ers gonna drain that pool at
night over four quarters and send that
mustachioed son of a [ __ ] back to
Kansas City with tears streaming down
his face in molasses-based barbecue
sauce in his stash you find out on
Sunday I have no idea who's gonna win I
think it's gonna be the 49ers that is my
guarantee they're gonna win put your
money on the 49ers take the point give
the point I don't give a [ __ ]
I like the 49ers the [ __ ] Kansas City
I didn't place [ __ ] in the playoffs they
play the [ __ ] Texans in a wild-card
team [ __ ] out of here get a state of
comedian I just pretended to be a cop
the last two days I've ran more than
I've ran in the last two decades I took
[ __ ] epson salt bath and I feel good
today what else more do you need in your
Super Bowl pic huh
good luck to everybody with the gambling
good luck to everybody if you're
watching a game with a bunch of broads
in the room we don't give a [ __ ] and
talking and buy broads I also mean
[ __ ] guys who don't watch sports you
know broads
right they're gonna run their yaps
during the game and shut up during the
commercial as always breaking a little
bit of a rule here I am going to a Super
Bowl party and I usually don't do that
but you know every couple of years I got
to be social right you know my wife is
such a she's such a great person she
wants to see other people she just
doesn't want you know she doesn't want
to see like you know me you know my
whole [ __ ] thinks so I'm gonna be a
good guy I'm trying to be a better guy
this decade all right trying to strip
another layer off the [ __ ] eggshell
whatever the [ __ ] idiots say anyways
alright that's the podcast please enjoy
the music from and roof emili´s and we
have a bonus half-hour special of
special bonus half-hour episode I should
say of the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
from a Thursday a couple years ago a
couple months ago I don't know how it
works alright have a great weekend you
[ __ ] and I will see you on Monday hey
what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's the
Monday morning podcast from Monday why
the [ __ ] isn't only in one ear what the
[ __ ] is with this I swear to God you
know what I'm putting it out there I
want I want an assistant alright and I
know what you think it oh I'm good with
computers [ __ ] you and your computers
I want another I want a whole other
level I'm putting this out to the
[ __ ] CIA I want a goddamn clone to
start doing this a clone who's funny and
knows how to work this [ __ ] why is it
only in one [ __ ] year hello hey
what's going on all right [ __ ] it we're
gonna roll with it oh you know what bill
you could stop and listen back to it to
see if it sounds okay you could do that
you know do you have that ability what
do you just plow through regardless of
whether it's working for you in life or
not I think
is a reoccurring theme what's going on
it's bill burr it's the Monday morning
podcast from Monday January 30th 2012 as
you can see I'm a little blue a bit
grumpy
kind of in a grumpy mood despite the
fact I finally have it down here in this
room is it really gonna cut in and out
like this oh I see it's the headphone
wire so everything else is fine
right so what it is looks like I need
some new Falken headphones mate come on
man don't [ __ ] do this to me the
whole [ __ ] podcast I'm gonna sit here
and feel like I'm underwater let's see
if we just do it like that what if we
move it over here can you believe it
this passes off as a [ __ ] podcast you
guys are actually listening to me doing
the sound check right there there's a
minute forty five you'll never get back
I just figured I'd say that before
somebody emailed it to me you know with
with you know hashtag epic fail you know
somehow they never feel like their level
of failure the fact that you would
actually sit here and listen to this
horseshit hey speaking of failure I
actually went onto YouTube and I know
they say everybody's seen these a
zillion times you know what I love I
love those compilation you know fail
videos of 2010 2011 and I was watching
those laughs night just laughing my ass
off just having a good time were you
bilk is there any that you can remember
not really a lot of face plants a lot of
people taking it in the nuts and I'll
tell you I can't believe what it takes
to break your [ __ ] neck because
everybody was like doing backflips and
then like waterskiing on their face like
landing on their face and sliding three
feet on their face and you're thinking
there's no way that guy's getting up and
every time they get they get right back
up this is something that I've noticed
about the leg is a lot of them because
they spent their whole [ __ ] lives
trying to attract a man
and who when veritably is gonna
disappoint him
because he's a [ __ ] idiot cuz he has
a dick right they spent so much time
poof in their hair and Peyton up their
goddamn faces you know like some kabuki
clown getting out of a goddamn
Volkswagen that day a lot of them have
the coordination of like a
three-year-old you know I'm not talking
about the athletic ones the ones that
throw like dudes you know have a little
grunt in there you get a new girlfriend
you didn't realize yeah you played high
school softball oh that's cool let's go
outside and play catch right
cheesy see it she's already [ __ ]
amped up you know she gets out there
he's got that look in her eye or [ __ ]
nipples are hard she's ready to go and
you're out there going oh you know it's
lady let's let's be easy
so you tosser one you know borderline
under underhanded trying to respect her
vajayjay right she's got a vagina not
too hard you'll love it over to her and
then she throws it back and Ruth gets a
little grunting there Pop's you mitt
makes your hand sting a little bit makes
you a little bit nervous right the [ __ ]
am I going with I'm not talking about
women like that I'm talking about you
know though my god you guys that's so
mean look at the Christmas lights I love
Christmas that girl
those when they fall off [ __ ] tables
or whatever the [ __ ] if they're going
on rope swings like when they fall they
look like a [ __ ] tautly no like
toddlers don't realize they do they
don't know enough to put their hands out
to protect their face or they just fall
like a [ __ ] sack of potatoes those
are my favorite videos cuz it's usually
good looking women you don't they're
good-looking so they know that all they
gotta do is just do that kabuki thing if
everyday they just [ __ ] wake up take
one of those giant powdered things and
slam their face with it paint their lips
red like a goddamn bull's eye that you
know much so a lot of people chagrin
most of their dreams are gonna come true
are they gonna come true
you know what is with the red lipstick
everybody I used to think was cuz your
lipstick you know sort of a red but it's
a muted red you know it's an old-school
TV red as opposed to the hi-def HD
[ __ ] sticky a dick in here red that
the lipstick is you know I'm officially
an old bastard you know this is this is
when you and in for all you youngsters
out there this is when you you know
you're gonna know that you're old
first of all you're gonna stutter
uncontrollably for no apparent reason
but beyond that this is how you're gonna
know you're old is when you get to that
age where you can't tell if somebody is
a hooker or if they work at the
basically like a library or something
hack god damn it I should have a better
example I can't tell the difference
between a girl going out to the club or
a girl walking down the street sucking
dick for twenty bucks a pop you know
because I've been old long enough that
you know my idea of what a [ __ ] is the
[ __ ] of my generation already have
kids who were like 18 19 20 years of age
all right so now they're rebelling
against their [ __ ] of a mother from the
80s early 90s so they have to outdo what
she did and in the process they dress
like hookers dressed when I was coming
of age I'm telling you when I'm out here
and I Drive down Hollywood Boulevard
where all the club scene is you know G
pill why do you go that way there's all
kinds of traffic's cuz I want to look at
the ladies right they're all out there
I'll tell you what's in now thick thighs
thank God about [ __ ] time now when I
was a kid like a women they all had
those skinny [ __ ] legs you know those
little chihuahua legs you know and they
have [ __ ] mustard colored pumps from
the 80s remember those girls now all of
a sudden it looks like this whole
generation has been doing squats
it's looking pretty good to me so
anyways what the [ __ ] am I talking about
oh I was talking about why I was you
know I have no idea what that thought
came from
did I end up on mustard pumps I can't
back it up my brain doesn't go that way
you know I just have to keep going
forward which is why I'm sitting here
with the podcasts only going into my
left ear and not my right ear but you
know what I'm not like you feel bad for
me but you know what I this has been a
problem that's been a reoccurring
[ __ ] problem and all I do is wiggle
the wires every week and be like okay
now it's working you know knowing full
[ __ ] well that something Bad's gonna
happen it's like ignoring the fact that
you know the ant check engine light just
came on Oh God
you know I told you I bought a truck
last week I took the [ __ ] driver's
side mirror off trying to back it into
my [ __ ] garage at 2:00 in the morning
trying to back this thing coming down
the [ __ ] thing and and my driveway
looks like it looks like nine people
built it and had like [ __ ] 12
different ideas and the garage is built
you know house is old so the garage is
built for like a [ __ ] Model T Ford
so it's skinny and really high so I have
a no problem with the truck fitting in
from the from the ground to the roof but
on the side I got like a coat of paint
and everybody who's come in going dude I
don't know how to [ __ ] your back in that
thing in here and I'm like well you know
I go real slow and blah blah but I came
down at night I was driving in at night
I was tired and I didn't flip the garage
light on and I started backing up going
out [ __ ] I didn't flip the garage light
and I was like a [ __ ] I got this
right I got this I got the reverse
lights and my truck is also a stick
shift so I got light and and this this
is the degree of difficulty alright
it tapers down like a funnel except not
equally you understand like one's coming
in say ones coming in at a 30-degree
angle
the others coming in like the other side
comes in like a 45-degree angle it's the
most [ __ ] up driveway I hate the
[ __ ] driveway
alright I said it I [ __ ] hate it I
sit there fantasizing figuring out how
to [ __ ] I can fix it and there's no way
to fix it because I live in a city and
right next
my neighbor's property there's nothing I
can [ __ ] do oh did I mention it also
goes down at like a 45 degree angle and
I have a stick shift so when you get
down to the bottom obviously you know
there could be a water issue so they had
this little like u-shaped thing for the
water to collect in that's about a foot
and a half two feet wide and then it
goes back up again and it's really steep
so the thing is I back in right as he
get to the garage doors right where I'm
starting to have a coat of paint then I
got to hit the gas again let out the
clutch to get it up and over that and I
thought I was okay and I just clipped a
mirror and it [ __ ] snapped right off
and it landed right underneath the truck
and I'm sitting there it's 2:00 in the
morning I can't wake up Nia I know the
[ __ ] mirror is under the truck I'm
just and I can't get out cuz I can't
open the doors on either side it's that
[ __ ] tight so now I'm just going like
alright please God don't let it be
underneath the truck
maybe I'll luck out and I pull out and
just here you know I [ __ ] drove over
the mirror and I'm absolutely sick about
it until I picked up the mirror cause I
thought it was the originals and it was
this plastic piece of [ __ ] so I was like
I'll [ __ ] it I can fix this it's a
couple of screws maybe I can go to a
junkyard and get the originals okay so
something positive came out of it so
[ __ ] mad at myself I should just
drove in you know what you know why it
happened because I was being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] because my truck is so loud I've
been I've been pulling it in straight
alright because because it's a pain task
to back in because I had a couple of
moments where I almost [ __ ] took off
the mirror so I've been driving in and
straight but the thing is is when I go
to back it out the problem is is you
know the engines a little cold I sit
there I gotta warm it up but blah blah
blah and then I got to go up that 45
degree angle and things gonna [ __ ]
stall out so I got to give it a lot of
gas and it's the loudest it just goes
blah blah blah blah promise I'm going up
the [ __ ] back drive back of the
driveway right sorry about the phone and
now there's always my [ __ ] neighbors
peeking out the window with their nose
is all wrinkled up so I'm like alright
I'm the new guy in town I don't wanna
piss these [ __ ] people off you know
let me back in it cuz then you know I I
just feel like I got more control when
I'm driving straight out because I could
see what the [ __ ] I'm going
you know when I'm back in that [ __ ] up
and I know I don't want it to stall out
I gotta fly it the [ __ ] driveway but
going to speed that in case somebody's
coming down the sidewalk I don't [ __ ]
run them over because my driveway so
steep I can't even [ __ ] sail all the
way up so wow so why do I [ __ ] go to
back in him what the [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what my goddamn
phone never rings the first week I got
it down here to the side it's gonna ring
every five seconds so anyways so the
reason why I basically this is what I
have this is what's killing me as a guy
cuz I said you know it's a plastic piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] mirror who gives a [ __ ]
I'm gonna get the I'm gonna somehow find
the originals okay what's pissing me off
is that the reason I have to do this is
because I was concerned about what my
[ __ ] neighbors thought I didn't want
people to look at me with wrinkled noses
at my age how pathetic is that is it
illegal to have a loud car I guess maybe
it is I don't know she's trying to be a
[ __ ] nice guy I don't [ __ ] know
it's annoying the hell out of me I give
up so if anybody knows where to find
some f100 parts for a 68 you know if you
got a good place where I can find
something like that please give me the
head heads up alright I'd love you
forever I want to try to get the
original ones that were made out of
[ __ ] metal and probably would have
taken out my garage doors as opposed to
tapping out like that I was going like
half a mile an hour and the sideview
mirror just went oh and fell off the
[ __ ] truck you know what I'm glad it
fell off it's not [ __ ] manly enough
to be on that [ __ ] there you go and
expose the one on the other side too ah
Christ I'm sick anyways so I'm gonna
grumpy ass mood already and you know why
cuz I actually got up at like 5:00 in
the morning to call in the wonderful
Opie and Anthony program you know had to
call them up because I got some gigs
coming up in Jersey that's what it is so
I went on there and it only should have
been like a 10
in a phone call but I was having so much
fun I stayed on for like an hour and a
half so I was up from 5 a.m. my time to
6:30 and then went back to bed
I don't know how about mess this week so
I don't even know you know I hey what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about
we decided to have a [ __ ] party for a
new place you know you think that was my
idea do you think it was my idea to have
a bunch of strangers coming to the
[ __ ] house I'll have people over
that's what I do
hey you want to come over and watch the
game nine people that I know right have
all your [ __ ] phone numbers you know
Nia is a more open person so she's like
let's have a party all right so we
search goes invite your friends so I'm
all right so you know I got you know I'm
a I'm a guy I don't have a bunch of
friends okay I got six good friends for
that I could really trust you know it's
about it at least out here I'm gonna
over here Nia talking to her mom about
all excited about the party and she's
like yeah I sent it out on foots
Facebook and I was just like oh my god
did I just invite a hundred and ten
people and my heart literally sank going
please tell me you didn't just invite a
hundred and ten [ __ ] people she's
like don't worry they're not all gonna
show up it's like yeah but like a third
will and then they're gonna bring people
that you don't even [ __ ] know and
that's exactly what happened it was a
[ __ ] great party I'm not gonna lie to
you but I gotta admit like I got to
learn how to UM be I thought I was gonna
be a good host I was and I wasn't I was
all right with the people I knew but the
people I didn't know actually most of
them are alright but there were a couple
of them died just fine it just says
there's something [ __ ] annoying about
somebody you don't know sitting on your
goddamn couch you know eating your food
drinking your booze like who the [ __ ]
are you that somebody else was laying
down on the floor I felt like the kids
dad I wanna get him get a [ __ ] job
alright it's over you 26 you [ __ ] bum
so anyway so the party's going great and
I'm basically the whole time you know
not drinking too much but I'm standing
by the front door because that's the
only way out all right and nobody's walk
out with any of my [ __ ] right I'm acting
basically like psycho and [ __ ]
stripes how I am it's how I'm wired all
right
so [ __ ] three-quarters way through
the party everything's going great I'm
like wow this is yeah you know what I
forgot I forgot I'm not 21 anymore I'm
[ __ ] 43 all my friends are adults and
everybody's drinking responsibly and no
one's really hammered nothing got broken
everything's cool so start just as I was
starting to relax some kid comes up to
me he's like yay dad you own the house
and I'm like well the bank owns it I'm
[ __ ] paying it off what can I do for
you
and he's like yeah it's kind of
embarrassing but I used the bathroom
downstairs and it's clogged now and I
was wondering if he had a plunger and I
was like yeah I do have a plunger I got
a plunger right here the upstairs
bathroom so I give it to the guy and I
and I say man I appreciate your honesty
he goes no problem he goes downstairs he
takes care of it
comes back he once again he goes he goes
sorry about that I said not at all not
at all what the [ __ ] it's a toilet
you know clogs up everyone small but I
appreciate appreciate your honesty you
know cuz I would have been nasty good
for you right so uh now the couple hours
goes by the party ends and there's like
one straggler left and I tell the story
to me I'm like you know what a good what
a good guy what a good [ __ ] no pun
intended you know we could have left it
in there and then the other party I come
walking in my [ __ ] bathroom looks
like a goddamn Port Authority bus
station toilet you know so psyched so
one of the stragglers at the party goes
yeah he goes I saw that whole thing go
down that's not exactly how it went down
I like what he talked about he goes he
goes it wasn't him that was in the
bathroom and I go who was he because it
was his girlfriend someone took a dump
of a magnitude that it wouldn't go down
the toilet so now she's in there
panicking and this is when today's
technology kicks in she can back in the
day she would had to crawl out the
[ __ ] window and hope nobody saw her
and just let
the door locked everybody would have
panicked holy [ __ ] who's in there did
somebody pass out is somebody is
somebody committing suicide someone want
it kicked in the door alright knocked it
off the [ __ ] goddamn hinges and you
go in there there'd be nobody in there
you'd feel the air from outside and then
look down and everyone would see a giant
[ __ ] and be like well how the party
would be over and the owner of the house
would be walking around going oh right
that's how would it ended but because of
today's technology I'm not saying she
didn't panic you know it's even worse as
a lady cuz they're not even supposed to
do stuff like that right and she was
able to text her boyfriend and I would
[ __ ] pay at least $400 to read those
texts the panic in those texts and to
his credit he [ __ ] he eats he stepped
it up he took the hit he came up to me
vh1's I love the 80s own Bill burr and
said I took a dump on your toilet to a
magnitude it didn't go down and I need
the tools required to alleviate this
situation so anti douchebag of the week
that guy right there said taking a
[ __ ] bullet for the team that gave
that right there is the reverse peyton
manning award he didn't [ __ ] ago we
had protection issues right now he took
one he took one for the [ __ ] team
went upstairs like a goddamned gentleman
asked for a plunger gave it to him it
was all fun and I went down there at the
end of the party you never would have
known anything anything happened yeah I
mean like you know three hours after the
Kennedy assassination I bet it was it
was all him say it you know marked it
all up and everything was all figured
out it but it was a nice road again
mopped up the brains what am I talking
about um anyways this is a podcast for
what is it January 30th minute [ __ ]
goddamn payments do again
why did I do this I was debt free
everybody I was living a debt-free life
and now I'm back on the wheels right
with that [ __ ] banker [ __ ] wants me
um anyways let's let's break into the we
got some advertising this week everybody
as always on the Monday morning podcast
if you're gonna buy anything off
amazon.com this week just go to Bill
burr com click on the podcast and you'll
see the window on the right-hand side
underneath the itunes banner and just
click on that if you go to amazon.com
through billboard.com on the podcast
page i will get credit for driving
traffic there it's a great way to
contribute to the podcast and 10% of all
proceeds will go to the Wounded Warriors
Project and you know we're doing all
right off of that so I want to thank all
you guys and I was actually talking to
my advertising guy you know about all of
this and I'm going you have to [ __ ] and
let me know you know all the numbers and
all that type of [ __ ] cuz I'm not gonna
be one of these [ __ ] guys that gets
busted on one of those investigative
reporting shows and he said it was going
to the Wounded Warriors Project ten
percent
turns out it was only two then I'm
[ __ ] Stan and they're all sweating
well you know I drink a lot and I was
trying I don't want to be that guy so
I'm gonna make sure every last goddamn
Don I'm ain't even [ __ ] go 11% she
keeps you that the [ __ ] pricks away
from me so anyways we have some more I
got some more advertising this week once
again everybody we're almost into
February and you know what that means
it's Valentine's Day right and it's a
day for the ladies despite the fact
you're both in the relationship only the
guy is for some reason has to buy the
woman something for the life of me I
can't figure it out it has got to annoy
you on some level as a guy right like
the whole thing is just like oh you
should just be happy then why don't you
celebrate that you're with me isn't this
supposed to be some sort of guide date
around here like Sadie Hawkins day isn't
there one day where they should go out
and get you some flowers in a [ __ ]
12-pack something maybe they take the
hit that month on the cable bill and pay
for the [ __ ] NBA or NHL Channel
maybe they could do that can I tell you
something ladies that would be that
would be that's the guy version of a
bouquet or bouquet whoever the [ __ ] you
say it police police of flowers the guy
version of a bouquet I would say bouquet
bouquet bouquet a [ __ ] thing of
flowers that was literally porky pigs
bit without stuttering a thing of
flowers our version of that is if you
actually make the payment for the NFL
Network that month you know it's about
the same price right
so anyways Valentine's Day is coming up
you know what you got to do it's all
about showing your love and not pissing
off your [ __ ] girlfriend that's what
it's all about right so what do you want
to do you go to proflowers.com everybody
just like we did last year on Mother's
Day you know it's funny in the copy here
they literally have that line that all
women say what did he get you for
Valentine's Day and it says that's what
her friends will be asking her and
they're absolutely right and they're
gonna be judging you you know so I don't
know what else you're gonna get her but
just to just to like this is the top of
the line up your leadoff hitter you go
to proflowers.com this is what's so
great you can do it at home it doesn't
require shopping everything that we hate
okay all you do is you go to
proflowers.com you type in the code name
bur be URR so I get the credit I get a
little kickback I pay off Jimmy Hoffa
right everything's good and I 429 98 you
get a dozen roses plus a vase free
chocolates and a teddy bear 2998 Jesus
Christ huh 30 bucks you get all of that
sitting at your damn desk you order it
alright oh you can even upgrade
long-stemmed roses for $9.99 more red
roses a classic romantic all that type
of stuff you can't go wrong with this
stuff so basically all you got to do is
you can call 800 ProFlowers and mention
birbee URR I'll go to the proflowers.com
click on the microphone
alright forgot this part you got to
click on the microphone in the top right
hand corner
and type in / b you are r and and then
that's it you're all ready you order
this order now and this deal is only
available until Friday February 10th at
midnight so yeah she desk right now just
bang it out you got it done and you can
relax a little bit you don't have to
worry about it you know anyone then what
you do after that you go make a
reservation it's some sort of restaurant
and you're all good right you're all
good or is that not enough
female listenership you know what I want
to hear from the ladies I want to know
what that what the [ __ ] are you gonna do
for Valentine's Day huh what are you
gonna do for me I told you guys what I
do I always go out on the 15th I'm
telling you just go out the day after
every restaurant in towns wide open they
all got reservations and the food is
priced the way it should be it's a good
deal
just like proflowers.com how'd you like
that tie them both together and I
believe every goddamn word of this [ __ ]
that's the best part go out on the 15th
go out on the 13th don't go out on the
14th that's like going down to Walmart
the day after Thanksgiving why would you
do it face pressed up against the glass
you know very least you're gonna get
your shoulder dislocated right oh my god
that is the worst night you could ever
go out as a man with your woman okay the
re so many relationships are gonna end
so many women are gonna be expecting
rings and not get them and on top of all
that they're all gonna be all [ __ ]
competitive look at another couples
looking at the other women seeing what
they're wearing oh my god it feel fat
look at that [ __ ] over there are you
looking at her you don't need it you
don't need it go out on the 15th all
right like goddamn lady and a gentleman
you sit down you pay the price that it
should be and you know did you go out on
the 50 to a nice [ __ ] restaurant
evenly these celebrity chefs I swear to
god three-quarter suit through the meal
like this chefs gonna come out he'll
come out to your table he's got nothing
to do he made all his money he's in a
great mood he's [ __ ] getting drunk
he's standing there
his Food Network clogs right I don't
know I don't know what you guys want
from me um oh hey let's talk Super Bowl
Super Bowl Super Bowl it's coming up
what's coming up this weekend I got a
question for all my listeners why the
hell are the Patriots favorites can
anybody explain that to me
the Giants should be the favorites they
should be carrying that pressure why am
i Patriots carrying that pressure we
played the Giants this year and they
beat us right how did we get to the
Super Bowl we played a Jesus Freak with
a high school offense beat him forty
five to ten right because he couldn't
walk in the water and then next week we
can you say we won that game we didn't
they got [ __ ] on a call and then they
missed the 32 yarder and next thing you
know we're in the Super Bowl and I
understand you need luck to win a
championship as much as you need skill
but come on all right
meanwhile the Giants beat Green Bay in
Green Bay
they beat San Francisco in San Francisco
I mean come on and they already beat us
how are we three two and a half three
point favors I don't for the life of me
I don't understand it I want to be the
underdog if we're the underdog I feel
like we can win that's my thing this
year that's my gut feeling we're the
underdog we're gonna win it if we're the
favourite we're gonna lose I don't know
why I don't know why I feel that but uh
I really I can't get a feeling for this
game I really can't every time I think
the Patriots are gonna win I just keep
picturing Tom Brady's standing on the
sidelines in the beginning of the fourth
quarter just shaking his head like when
am I gonna get the [ __ ] ball back can
somebody please tackle Brandon Jay
Brandon Jacobs is that his [ __ ] name
a goddamn refrigerator with a helmet you
know that's the funny thing they used to
call that one guy refrigerator Perry he
didn't look like he looked like beanbag
like a beanbag he didn't look like a
[ __ ] refrigerator when I say beanbag
twice I was kidding who I'm [ __ ]
nervous I don't want to lose to the
goddamn Giants again and they're a
better [ __ ] team all the way around
other than at the quarterback position
but even then that's close enough
I think because Eli plays his best in
the biggest games and once again this is
gonna be like it's it's set not to be an
upset when when the better team is
actually an underdog it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] we should be the underdog I
want to be the underdog that's what I
want let us be the underdog and Tom
Brady will get extra [ __ ] mad
and hopefully despite the fact that he
might spend half the game on his back
he'll be able to just will us to a
goddamn victory all right so that's my
feeling I have no confidence whatsoever
I'm not talking any [ __ ] and if we win
next week I'm not talking any [ __ ] I'm
not talking any because that's how I do
it if I feel confident I talk [ __ ] and
it happens that's when I talk [ __ ] but I
don't I don't I have zero [ __ ]
confidence in this game as far as I look
at it on paper I just think they're the
better team they got a way better
defense I talked about all this [ __ ]
last week hang on what's up
the lovely Mia everybody who gave me the
chair down here no I'm not done you have
a question okay all right well I'll talk
to you in a minute okay please leave my
sanctum here my podcasting sanctum
goodbye um all right that's it let's
let's let's get on with the podcast this
is the Monday morning podcast everybody
I hope you're having a lovely Monday I
hope you were enjoying the Monday that
you're having you know did anybody watch
the Pro Bowl don't tell me what happened
I taped it um worst [ __ ] all-star
game ever it was already like a letdown
because no one's gonna try hard because
they play tackle football right you know
the NHL all-star game they don't check
each other they just out there they
having a good time they have an ax
laughs his Ricky Gervais says NBA they
just throwing alley-oops nobody's
playing defense right nobody's wearing a
cup that [ __ ] dicks hanging out of
this short they don't give a [ __ ] right
and in baseball baseball you know
there's no prospect brushback pitches
probably the pitcher has it the worst
because they got to go out there and
actually try so they don't get
shown up but every else is just having a
good [ __ ] time but the football date
they I don't know you still got to
tackle each other so now they put it
between right before the Super Bowl so
no one is playing in the Super Bowl is
gonna be there I don't know I don't
[ __ ] like it but I got to tell you
guys this I saw one of the most brutal
sports I've seen in my life the lingerie
football league has anybody seen that
and first of all with all the bitching
that women do I don't know how the I
don't know who the the chauvinistic
genius was that got this [ __ ] on the air
but Nia somehow found it and I'm not
putting that on her I swear to god she
clicked through and she found this [ __ ]
and I sat there watching it and I'm
thinking like oh wow logic women playing
football in lingerie this is gonna be
sexy on some level and I got to tell you
it was actually uh I don't think I
winced more watching that sport than I
have any other four major sports it just
looks really [ __ ] painful they're
playing on like [ __ ] astroturf with
goddamn like Larry Bird shorts look like
magic job Michael Jordan shorts compared
these girls got like shorts up their
[ __ ] goddamn they got like road rash
on their butt cheek they're wearing like
half shirts and every one of them has
like these red burn marks on their body
it was just I don't know I didn't like
it just like why they did why would you
why would you do this you ever think
[ __ ] like that you know
I understand women wanted to do like the
fun stuff of being a guy like actually
going out and getting paid a decent wage
to do a job like it's so [ __ ] up women
make less an hour it really is but you
know they can get caught up in that [ __ ]
and they can start being like listen we
want to do everything that you do even
the dumb [ __ ] let's just say they gave
you all the pads let's just say they did
that let's just say you actually got to
go out there on the field like a
respectable [ __ ] human being with
actual pants on
in a full shirt covered up and protected
like why would you why would you want to
do it it's never gonna be bigger than
the NFL you know you're not even gonna
make WNBA money all right
then on top of that you gotta you're
gonna have your brain rattling around in
your skull you know why would you want
to do that there was absolutely nothing
funny about that it was just it was was
just difficult to watch how the [ __ ] did
they get that I don't understand you
know recently a very good friend of mine
got demoted on some [ __ ] you know he
was doing an interview and they asked
him about women comment comics and he
made some sort of comment and then all
of a sudden this defines him as a person
you know and he gets busted down he goes
to my sergeant they bust him back down a
couple of ranks somehow he gets [ __ ]
but somehow you know despite the fact
this guy was quoted in a major paper I
think the Washington Post like a year
earlier going some of the funniest
people in standup are women he has that
quote out there in the media somehow
that didn't balance out like oh maybe we
miss quoted him maybe we're not
understanding what he's saying no
benefit of the doubt that was said go
[ __ ] yourself
right that's the world we live in where
he gets called on his [ __ ] but [ __ ]
Kobe's wife you know who stuck around
those actions those last three years so
she could make money for the rest of her
[ __ ] life that bum goddamn freedo
debris in her cleavage from sitting on
the [ __ ] couch doing nothing nobody
questions that [ __ ] or questions the
lingerie League there's got to be some
[ __ ] out there some sort of women's
league complaining about that oh my god
we have hit a new low I love how they
always like that type of [ __ ] is like a
new low for the exploitation of women
but for some reason all these
gold-digging [ __ ] who are just clearly
there for the money sucking dick for
[ __ ] money
they never
have a problem with any of these divorce
settlements when was the last time one
of these lai groups had a [ __ ]
problem with any of that [ __ ] that's why
I don't like these [ __ ] groups all
right
this selfish oh they just give a [ __ ]
about their [ __ ] cause and that's it
okay and their whole agenda is is the
cause first truth be damned
there's no oh how did you mean that [ __ ]
you were burying you under the house
that's it
[ __ ] you and your career we need hits on
our website that would define what I'm
talking about I'm just [ __ ] I'm just
upset that was a good friend of mine
still is a good friend of mine and it
was absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
so sick of people complaining that this
unfair business was unfair to them
alright go on stage and be undeniable
all right you do that you're gonna be
fine okay then you don't have to worry
about what's [ __ ] between your legs
go [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself all right man a woman
when's the last time you went on stage
and you killed so [ __ ] hard this show
is over for the next to next two comics
were up on stage and they had to deal
with what the [ __ ] you just did okay if
you're doing that on a regular basis
you're not gonna have a problem all
right if you're not doing it I don't
give a [ __ ] whether you have a vagina or
a dick you have work to do maybe you're
a writer maybe you're a director fine
will you fit in the business and you're
gonna be fine you know do you think the
[ __ ] Hollywood is banging down the
door to [ __ ] book a balding redhead
in his 40s you think I don't have you
think I don't have my challenges look at
me
20 years in the business I'm sitting in
a room by myself talking to myself for a
[ __ ] hour where's my group where's my
website where's all those [ __ ] people
going to be outraged for
the plight of the balding redhead I can
tell you right now it doesn't exist
so go [ __ ] yourself I don't have any
[ __ ] sympathy I don't I'm done with
it I don't believe in handouts it
doesn't help the person it helps him for
a week that's it it's like that that
that story about the guy who gave the
person a fish or a taught amount of fish
right give a man a fish he says hey
thanks a lot
teach a man to fish and he's like I
don't want I have a vagina
you know ladies let me ask you a
question how easy do we have to make it
to the point where you feel it's fair
that's what the that's my big [ __ ]
question how far up how much further up
do you get to tee off on the golf course
and still write down the same score as
if you are as good as the [ __ ] poor
bastard thirty yards behind you it's
[ __ ] unreal you go golfing with the
goddamn woman it's like every hole you
go on to it's like you took a personal
foul on the last play that'll be added
on to the kickoff right it's just you
know the genius of women is their
[ __ ] organized guys we're not
organized that's what the problem is
okay and ever since we back in the day
when you know you could [ __ ] boot him
in the ass right in public no one would
do a [ __ ] thing they got organized
and they put a stop to that [ __ ] and we
just we've just been going all right all
right all right all right okay all right
for [ __ ] a hundred years and now
we're in this [ __ ] situation that no
job having bum-ass women can be worth 70
million dollars and no one even bats an
eye at it you know it's the one I would
start having sympathy for for women and
their goddamn plight in the world is
when you have the [ __ ] common decency
to tee off from where the [ __ ] I tee off
okay you want it to be equal back it up
30 there sweetheart
[Laughter]
do you realize how quickly out if I ever
decided to run for president I would be
one of the most he just
any podcast just spin the wheel pick any
one of them in the campaign would be
over I don't know how those guys do it
those people who [ __ ] run for
president I have know like it's like
when do you get it out you know and I'm
not even talking like man woman [ __ ] I'm
just talking about that the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] complaining that all these
[ __ ] losers you know winners don't
complain you know whatever they shake it
off they play the [ __ ] game again the
next day that's what they do
losers [ __ ] wait a minute isn't my
whole podcast just about bitching oh
Jesus Christ I swear to God I'm such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I don't even need
anybody debate me like I actually lose
in a debate by myself
pathetic and with that one last piece of
advertising I didn't how to space these
things out I have a new a new
advertising this week we're gonna take a
commercial break everybody I could have
like music beds underneath this thing at
some point I have to be a little more
professional we have new advertisers
this week the monday morning podcast
would like to welcome stamps comp i
brought this up a few weeks ago about
you know going down to the post office
you stand in those unbelievably long
lines alright and you know me I'm all
about that I will stand in the line at
the grocery store rather than using
those automated machines I will do that
you know why that is but I don't like
doing it at the post office because
there's a bunch of grumpy people work in
there and you stand in the whole damn
line and but right as you get up there
going oh my god I'm next the next they
put up that little side next window
please
and then they sit down on the eat their
sandwich in full view so then what are
you doing you walk over to the damn
automated machine alright you forced me
over here and then there's somebody in
front of you and they can't figure out
how to use a thing all right well stamps
calm has the solution alright this is
basically what you do you go to stamps
com you're buying print a few key this
way you can do that you can buy and
print official US postage stamps so you
don't have to go to the post office
anymore they give you the paper they
hook me up this week I actually have a
mini post office right now in my office
I have a scale like
the paper to print the stamps out on I
got all of it alright and and I actually
was able to figure it out and I'm a
[ __ ] all right
totally convenient you go to stamps calm
if you go right now there's a special
offer you enter my last name birbee you
are are you get a no risk trial plus
$110 bonus offer including a digital
scale in fifty five bucks worth of free
postage for a limited time only of
course you know when do they ever say
it's forever
it's always limited that's right we're
trying to motivate you to get off your
ass go to stamps calm but before you do
anything when you go to stamps calm
click on the radio microphone on the top
of the homepage and you type in birbee
you are are stamps calm I don't know I
got to tell you I actually uh I can't do
advertising on this podcast unless I
actually use the stuff because then I'll
just feel like a total phony and I
actually uh I had them I had them send
me the scale I did the whole thing I
sent a package out to my brother ran the
whole thing off and I gotta admit it was
actually yeah it was a good damn time so
uh that's it I know I'm going against
everything that I've said about these
automated machines I just didn't post
office I don't know maybe do I have
exceptions is that what it is am I being
a sellout right now I don't think I am I
draw the line if you're a dick if I go
down to the post office and you're a
dick to me you know oh you know what I
did like is she actually had the option
to buy all kinds of different stamps
because uh that's what I hate about the
automated machine down at the post
office you kind of can only buy those
American flag ones as far as I know so
I'm usually so frustrated by the time I
get to it I like going down and buying
really happy silly stamps and then
mailing it out to people I hate like the
[ __ ] pricks who gave me my mortgage
you know
this goddamn scam that's why I sit down
here in this room with one chair and it
echoes in here cuz I have to pay off all
that [ __ ] money well know what else
am I supposed to do what was I supposed
to do they taken all my money
you know you can't just sit on the
sidelines you just can't do it you have
to participate or else they just come by
they turn you upside down they shake all
the [ __ ] money out of your pockets
cause I'll tell you right now I've had
it with the stock market you can go [ __ ]
yourself stock market I'm not doing it
anymore stock market is the biggest
goddamn scam ever it's for the [ __ ]
rich and they all get together next to a
pool you know what let's let's let's
just rip the rug out from underneath it
and in three weeks okay so everybody
attention sell all your [ __ ] sell all of
it we're yanking the rug out on Thursday
now next Thursday next Thursday Ruppert
next Thursday we're doing it right then
they yank it all out all the regular
guys fall to the pavement splat on the
ground and then those rich pick pricks
come back and then they buy low they've
been doing it every four years since
this [ __ ] started you put your money
in and you can't get it out I can't get
my money out oh I can get it out they're
just gonna take most of it they're gonna
give me a penalty for taking it out
early I swear to God all the money
having the stock market I don't even
think about it anymore it's like it's
gone there's nothing I could do
it's just you know I don't know I I want
to buy stuff that I can touch from here
on out that's what it is
I'm gonna buy precious metals [ __ ]
I'm gonna buy a goddamn avocado tree you
know that's what I want because it's not
like some day I just walk outside the
[ __ ] trees gone or it's like an
eighth of a size that it was you know I
know I got a little Dixie cup of water
hang in there bill hang in there not to
turn around sometime in the next eight
years [ __ ] that say what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about this has been such a weird
podcast I'm never doing a podcast again
when I have to wake up at 5:00 in the
morning then go back and sleep again do
you know what that goddamn Joe DeRosa
did Joe DeRosa hustled me Opie and
Anthony and dr. Steve today you guys
should really listen to the the replay
of the Opie and Anthony show today those
were fans of the the uninformed show
that I did with Joe DeRosa back in the
day and I am speaking about it in the
past tense because you know I hate to
say this but Joe unbeknownst to me has
been cheating on me for the last like
six months he's on Bobby Cup Bobby
Kelley's uh you know what dude podcast
you know a typical Joe he wasn't a man
about it
he didn't say listen bill you know I've
met somebody else this long-distance
relationship thing just isn't working
out for me
I thought it would you'll always have a
special place in my heart he didn't he
just walked his half Egyptian ass over
to the subway and went over to Bobby
Kelly
dude come on over my apartment you'd you
know what I did and he's been doing that
podcast over there
you know what others you know what I
feel about it I actually feel relief you
know like when you break up with that
psycho and your [ __ ] buddy starts
dating them and you're like yeah that's
all you buddy
Saul you man I give it my blessing Bobby
Kelly I give it my blessing good luck
with Joe DeRosa okay yeah you know what
Bob I hope you're listening to this how
much is he already complaining as he
complained yet that you pick on him too
much is that what's happening does he
feel like he's not being respected on
the show does he want his name in lights
on your show well what about what else
I'm just gonna [ __ ] drive a wedge
between both those [ __ ] I'm telling you
you know and then he's probably doing
his little passive-aggressive things
where he tries to take more territory
and then you give him [ __ ] and then he
says though that's not what I was doing
Oh Joe we know all your moves bad just
[ __ ] around I just like trash and Joe
and I actually owe that [ __ ] a
hundred bucks I owe that [ __ ]
100 bucks because those who you at least
listen to the the uninformed program a
long time ago I bet Joe for some reason
that he couldn't do five good push-ups
and was the funniest he actually did him
it was the funniest thing I ever saw he
liked the first and the first pushup
his arms were he was his arms were
shaking in the let's get ready to do my
first push up push up and he was so bad
he was actually laughing it was great
and so today for some reason that just
came back up and me and Opie Bennett and
dr. Steve bet him a hundred bucks each
said he couldn't do 20 push-ups so I
know Jojo doesn't [ __ ] work out so
I'm like he's gonna even if he's been
doing push-up he's gonna crap out at 11
and then we were given the option to
then do girl push-ups but he had to go
two to one so if he had nine left to get
to 20 if he was doing girls push-ups
he'd then have to do 18 and it was gonna
be hilarious cuz I was convinced that he
was gonna conk out doing girl push-ups
Huell unbeknownst and he played it great
go wait a min wasn't make it 15 make it
15 right totally hustled us like Fast
Eddie right unbeknownst to us he's been
working with a trainer Joe DeRosa with
his [ __ ] pretzel rod arms his tinman
barrel chest [ __ ] goes hits the deck
and just bangs him out and all and I'm
not there I can't hear it so all I hear
is Anthony count him going one two three
four five six and once he got to seven I
was like this [ __ ] you've been
practicing
I lost 100 bucks I'll last 100 bucks
before the goddamn Sun came up out here
I got hustled by Joe DeRosa and it bugs
me you know and that's why right now I'm
trying to drive a wedge between him and
Robert Kelly you know I love Bobby Kelly
Joe DeRosa I don't love I don't have any
love for him and I just feel it's a
shame that Bobby doesn't realize the
snake that he has led into his meerkat
house
[Laughter]
you know I'm telling you I'm already
gonna predict this that relationship
it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna end
ugly there is gonna be an epic [ __ ]
fight on that podcast and Bobby's gonna
call me a [ __ ] dent dude I'm [ __ ]
done with that kid dude I'm telling you
dude he doesn't know you he doesn't know
dude you don't rub my head dude it's
gonna be something Joe is gonna do
something Joe can't help but be [ __ ]
annoying it's what I love about is that
I'd really this is my over-under is that
June of next year by June of next year
I'll wait a minute probably happens
sooner than that they're gonna have a
couple of epic battles this year and
then by June of next year Joe's gonna
Joe's gonna be hitting the bricks again
he's kind of like that David Duchovny
character on Californication except
instead of broads it's podcast why am i
trashing Joe
why would I trash him you know why cuz
it's fun you know and the nerve of me to
sit here and talk about who has friends
or anything as I sit here and do this
[ __ ] thing all by myself all by
myself I'm ronery alright let's get to
the advice for this week oh no wait I
know what I'm gonna talk about internet
porn everybody internet porn
which is one of my favorite jokes Joe
DeRosa does and I tell you what it is
but then he can't do it um anyways so
I've been telling you guys how I've laid
off the porn all this year I had a
relapsed I watched watched a couple this
week and now I got to start over again I
got my one date chip today how do you
walk away I don't know how to walk away
from it I can't I am Who I am addicted
to internet porn I can't I can't stay
away from or I think I went almost 30
days I went about 30 days all right here
we go
so this
I rights he goes it goes hey that carrot
top so I heard on your last podcast that
you were trying to kick the internet
porn because of the crazy [ __ ] it took
to get you to get it get you off or
whatever how's that working out for you
because I have the exact same problem
and tried many times to kick that [ __ ]
see it's why I love this email because I
feel like there's a lot of other guys in
the same boat you guys whenever I tell
myself alright it's not healthy to watch
18 year old shoot golf balls out of
their ass let's calm down I stay away
for a while
but I find myself floating towards that
computer like Fred Flintstone when he
smells whatever that broad Wilma is
cooking and I'm not even sure if it's a
sexual issue which he spelt with two
exes like Nikki Sixx for some reason a
sexual issue because even when I'm in a
relationship having sex and all that
jazz I don't know why Roach as I still
do it
I still watch internet porn I could use
some tips before I yank my dick off one
day I'm not trained in that field you
know I have no idea I think you need to
go to some sort of jerking your dick
methadone clinic if they have it out
there there's got to be some sort of
addicted to porn thing you know I would
say I have a functional addiction you
know what I mean like it like we equated
this to alcohol like I drink but I don't
miss work you don't I mean I can shut it
down I don't you know but if I went by a
doctor's prognosis the amount of drinks
I have in a week I am an alcoholic I
look at the internet porn the same way
they would definitely diagnosed me with
an addiction but you know whenever I've
seen them show whenever it lives shown
people on TV with porn addictions it's
like they'd literally calling him sick
they lost their job they stay at home
just rubbing one out all day long
downstairs I don't know I actually think
my porn watching is just like my boozing
I think it got to a point and I realized
it was beginning to become a problem and
then I got a [ __ ] dial it back
although I was able to go a year in two
days without having a drop butt
the porn I've I only went 30 days I went
30 days so now I got I got a [ __ ]
start over again so dude I have no idea
I have no idea but I got to tell you
though you know it's like anything else
it takes six weeks to break a bad habit
and I went four so now I got a [ __ ]
start over again I don't know I think
it's just like drinking I'm now I'm not
gonna ever stop doing it a hundred
percent but I'm definitely gonna try and
keep it in check that's the best I can
give you but if anybody else has any
stories or knows anybody that has
literally been addicted to it and can
shine a light on it why don't you send
me your emails cuz I'll read them on
this thing because God knows I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna do any research you
know research about it Jesus Christ is
there any momentum left in this advice
for the week hey dear bill I started
dating this junior this girl a junior
and only two months ago left in my
senior year of college I totally read
that wrong I started dating this girl a
junior with the only two months left in
my senior year of college stupid I know
things were great she was cute and
extremely intelligent right there he hit
a [ __ ] triple uh I ended up sticking
around the area to get my MBA even
though she wasn't the reason I stayed I
would be lying if I said she didn't play
it play a small part I later found out
that she was a min she was a
manipulative and juvenile [ __ ] Jesus
what happened was all sunshine now okay
here we go or what the human races like
to call a woman you know just when I
think that I say the most misogynistic
[ __ ] you guys always you out
ignorant me well that's not even
expression all right I think I just took
back the title you out ignorant me you
out ignorant me I just said that and I
wasn't even joking anyways but for some
screwed-up reason I stayed with her
basically because she had some
depression issues and did I and I
legitimately cared for her dude I mean I
can tell you right now they got
depression issues just walk away
you know just walk away the degree of
difficulty it's harder than me [ __ ]
trying to back that truck into that
Model T Ford [ __ ] garage depression
issues and then you got it you just the
amount you're gonna have to give [ __ ]
[ __ ] that to people who have depression
should be with other people who have
depression and then they can both lay
there on the rug hmm what's the point
you sitting there all sunshiny like some
dog that wants to go outside and run
around and she's [ __ ] laying there
like the world's gonna end you don't
need that um anyways I got to the point
where she would break up with me every
other weekend but then want to get back
together within days I let this go on
for quite sometime because like I said
she had depression issues and to my
knowledge none of us would hook up with
anyone else while we were broken up
bet you can see where this one's going
there Billy Boy eventually I found out
she had hooked up with other guys yeah
on the weekend she broke up with you so
she wouldn't feel guilty eventually I
found out she had hooked up with a few
guys from the University one of them
happened to be one of my really good
friends this is a guy that I drove from
Indiana to Montreal to see the supposed
love of his life a few months earlier
who I'm I later found out he had cheated
on countless times needless to say I
never spoke to that douche again alright
so this girl actually did you a favor
cuz he could have stayed friends with
that guy and opened a business together
and then he goes da capo Co with all
your [ __ ] anyways I try to break it off
with her and get away but like the
manipulative [ __ ] she was every time I
was distance myself she would start
cutting her cutting herself and tell me
about how she was thinking about taking
her own life okay I was gonna make a
joke there but just to save my ass as a
liability thing I'm not gonna make the
joke but uh you guys ever see that show
name that tomb I can name that tune in
seven notes I can name that tune in five
notes I can name that tune in three
notes at some point you gotta go you
know what [ __ ] name that tune
[Laughter]
if this was a normal situation I would
tell her friends about what I was
hearing and let them deal with it but
since she had started being depressed
she had basically pushed every single
friend she had out of her life except me
I know she was depressed to an extent
but let me tell you that my job that my
depression runs in my have a depression
in my family oh Jesus you guys were made
for each other I've dealt with it in
some shape or form whether it was my
brother mother or even my own for the
majority of my life and this girl used
use it as an excuse to be an absolute
manipulative [ __ ] to get anything she
wanted and he's alright dude you keep
saying she's manipulative at some point
you know the only way someone can
manipulate you is if you if you let them
alright and I'm not giving you [ __ ] here
I'm giving you the power to get out from
underneath this okay
how many times you gonna try to kick the
football and she pulls it out and you go
flying on your back like that poor bald
bastard in that car too right you know
what you get two tits this this is the
life you want to live you're gonna marry
this girl have kids with this girl you
know every three days right let's break
up so I can blow the garbage collector
just walk away just walk away all right
he says I really have no idea what to do
I think she's just being she's a selfish
manipulative but if I'm wrong she ends
up taking a life I don't know what I
would do with myself if she ends up
taking a life I don't know I don't know
what to do with myself dude listen yeah
I'm gonna get in trouble legally if I
get I'm not gonna give any more advice
all right I'm gonna get in trouble with
this because this is like a serious
thing she's actually threatened that you
look you're not trained for this neither
am i go get her tell it again give her a
card
call this number get some professional
help and I don't you know you make up
your own mind on that one you want to
stay with that you stay with her if you
don't don't you know but anybody else
who's listening all right you know life
doesn't have to be that hard that's all
I'm saying all right let's move on let's
move on hello mr. Barr I've been
listening to your podcast for a few
months
and I've been catching up on as many of
your podcast as possible just listen to
the latest podcast and what a corker
it had me roaring my old fruit what the
[ __ ] does that mean
what country oh I'm English okay what a
corker it had me roaring my old fruit is
this somebody from England [ __ ] with
me just writing expressions that you
guys don't really use I'll play along
[ __ ] it I'll read all of this like this
is legitimate yeah it also got me onto
your stand up to which I used YouTube
and yes I viewed your material for free
dont you judge me
go [ __ ] yourself so list leads i don't
give a [ __ ] if you watch it for free
there i don't care so this leads onto
the question of when are you coming back
to jolly old England for tea crumpets
and soccer um all this guy's trying to
be funny oh come on soccer its football
it's a ball and you use your feet how
hard is it Jesus Christ this guy's doing
like 80s it's a bull you use your feet
OH although using the basis of American
American football would be hand egg calm
down dear it's only a joke isn't this
funny this guy in his head is killing
right now and I'm getting upset with all
these amazing points he's making sir do
you really think that you're the first
one from England that ever said you know
it's football
there's a ball and you kick it with your
foot why do you guys call it football
when ninety percent of the game you're
running with it and I always say it's
because it started off as your version
of football and we realized how [ __ ]
boring it is to run around with your
feeties kicking the [ __ ] ball around
and you can't use your goddamn hands
alright we decided why don't we pick the
[ __ ] thing up and try to run each
other over with it you know as opposed
to [ __ ] acting like you fell out of a
moving car at 40 miles an hour every
time somebody trips you alright
and all you rugby people go [ __ ] you
self I don't want to hear it came from
rugby I don't know where the [ __ ]
came from I don't give a [ __ ] alright
it's called football it's a man's sport
and it's way more enjoyable than your
version which is soccer your version
sucks alright rugby is way better than
soccer [ __ ] up and down the pitch 900
times it's so [ __ ] boring everybody's
singing campfire songs cuz they're just
waiting for something to happen I swear
to God that in cricket playing with that
fraternity paddle anyways well I'm
English pudding that is need there's in
need of some advice this guy sounds like
an old Queen so any help would be
appreciated and if your if your good
lady Nia is around with their opinions
that would be smashing - I've been with
my girl for two years and I've never
been more in love we're going through a
difficult patch right now but we're
clearly and why cuz you're wearing her
clothes we are we are clearly going
through a difficult patch right now but
we're we're clear clearly and openly and
are working through it for some reason
she seems to love me too now there's too
many issues to go through here I don't
want to take up too much of your time
well you just did with those two [ __ ]
sentences however about six months ago
into our relationship she sort of broke
my trust in her and I'm sure I'm not
sure if I'm ever gonna get over it it's
not like she got frisky with another
gentleman a lady she likes the Weed Man
too much though she told me that she
wasn't doing it anymore but the whole
time was was getting it from her brother
and doing it behind my back to be fair
I'm not a big fan of weed or drugs in
general then you know what I'm not
reading the rest of it walk you know
what to do to get what you want you got
it you got it have zero [ __ ]
tolerance okay until you have a feeling
when you have that feeling for somebody
we just like despite the fact that they
annoy the [ __ ] out of me there's
something about them then you with the
right person other than that you know I
don't want to hear it
you don't like drugs you're not a fan of
drugs she's doing drugs behind your back
she was dishonest about it you know
that's the tip of the [ __ ] iceberg
all right
just walk okay kick your soccer ball
down the [ __ ] Street and go find
somebody else go take out a personal ad
looking for a new bird over a ton rate
for the week I got to wrap this up this
is getting a little long here overrated
underrated underrated driving barefoot
I understand it's winter where you live
and probably not really cold but I know
you've lived in cold climates it's like
unprotected sex with a motor vehicle
pushing the throttle with just my big
toe almost gets me hard
underrated Geddy Lee's bass technique a
while ago in the podcast you talked
about how well Angus Young of ac/dc
developed his guitar technique and was
able to do so many great things with a
really simple guitar line I was actually
talking about Malcolm young Geddy Lee of
Rush is able to do a similar thing with
the bass line and spice up a song in a
way that fans would never expect yeah I
totally respect those guys obviously is
musicians I've just never been really a
fan of it's too nerdy too Dungeons and
Dragons for me I just never got into it
overrated the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
yeah I would say the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame is 90% overrated you know
looking at all those stupid jumpsuits
that people wore is boring it's like
walking into a clothing store and
there's nothing in there that you'd ever
[ __ ] wear and you want to get out of
there but there's [ __ ] four floors of
it you know but they did have stated at
some cool [ __ ] when I went there they
had John Bonham's green Sparkle Ludwig
drumkit and I'm not gonna lie to you if
I didn't just sit there with my jaw on
the ground staring at how [ __ ] little
it looked and just thinking of all the
[ __ ] music that came out of that
thing and all the songs you know that
they recorded on that that there was a
couple of things that I saw in there
that really just blew me away I'm into
that type of [ __ ] that
historical stuff if it's something I'm
into that if somebody actually like I
like performing in theaters where bands
are comedians that I was you know a fan
of actually performed it and then I
always get bummed out when they go you
know well this isn't the original stage
we rebuilt the stage that always [ __ ]
bums me out saying I want to stand on
the same [ __ ] wood they did I know
I'm weird like that but whatever anyways
that's the podcast for this week that
really just ended on a [ __ ] whimper
then it what do I got anything else am I
really gonna end on that am I just gonna
take a knee and run off the clock for
the half and get booed by the Hometown
[ __ ] fans I think that's all I got
you know I had a rough week okay I had
that [ __ ] party I took the sideview
mirror off can you guys please tell me
where the [ __ ] I can buy buy some parts
for a 68 f100 because I got to tell you
something man I was out in Texas when I
drove from Houston to Austin last week
and I got a tip from somebody to get off
the major highways and you're gonna find
all those old cars and junkyards and
[ __ ] and I found a great junkyard
actually off the highway and I pulled in
and it was like three the radius looking
houses you ever seen in a life in like
three football fields worth of old cars
behind it all right and I have the
original Jack to my truck but I don't
have the jack handle or the whole thing
that the spare used to be underneath the
truck I don't have any of that anymore
so I want to get that and put the spare
back underneath and get the old jack
handle if I could and so I pulled in to
this place and I just got freaked out
even though it was the middle of the day
there was all these keep out no
trespassing signs and there was three
different houses and I couldn't figure
out who owned it and it was [ __ ]
Texas so if there was an eight-year-old
in there the kid was gonna be strapped
and so I [ __ ] drove away so if
anybody knows in the LA area I'll start
there or if you go on my website and you
look at some of the gigs I have coming
up if you know like where am I gonna be
I got my redneck tour coming up wait a
minute this is perfect this is perfect
I'm gonna be at February 7th this is my
next gig
and we at the comedy zone in Charlotte
North Carolina on February 8th I'm at
the stardome comedy club in Hoover
Alabama and then I'm at the Buckhead
Theatre in Atlanta Georgia on the 9th
that's a Tuesday Wednesday Thursday my
redneck tour and I know that there's a
bunch of old f100 surround there so if
anybody knows a junkyard and I would be
driving that whole way all right
I'm driving Charlotte over to Alabama
then over to Atlanta then I'm flying
back home and I'm flying in and out of
Atlanta so I also drive up to Charlotte
so if you guys know any old junkyards
and [ __ ] like that out there I greatly
[ __ ] appreciate it because you know I
want to have this thing like this
[ __ ] truck is the [ __ ] it's like
everything I got the rig matching
numbers the original [ __ ] motor
cigarette lighter ashtray the whole
[ __ ] thing is just the steering wheel
all of it like I actually went on the
internet and I was looking at old f100
ads and they were showing the interior
and this thing hasn't been modified at
all it's got [ __ ] drum brakes no
power steering three on the tree it's a
[ __ ] monster it's a [ __ ] monster and
I got to back this [ __ ] out at a
45-degree angle and I wake up the whole
neighborhood so anyway so I want to get
the original side view mirror's as
opposed to the plastic pieces of [ __ ]
that are on the side and like I said if
you know any junkyards out there I
greatly appreciate it so that's it
that's the podcast for this week why
don't I end hype in my dates the other
dates I have coming up I'm gonna be
doing after that I do my redneck tour
and then come up to the East Coast and
I'm doing the tri-state area Bergen
Theatre February 16th Englewood New
Jersey then I'm doing the Fox Theater
and at Foxwoods Connecticut we just
added a second show so thank you to
everybody went out bought all this
tickets we've added a second show
February 17th and then I'm gonna be in
Westbury New York theater Westbury on
February 18th and that is the deal so
please come out once again thanks to
everybody's been coming out to my shows
i'm getting geared up to do my
special so you know no courtesy laughing
people just laugh at what's funny you'll
really be helping me out and if you
don't like what I said just [ __ ] sit
there and stare at me alright with the
dead silence I deserve alright that's
the podcast for this week once again go
to proflowers.com click on the
microphone type in ber get your flowers
your teddy bear your vase and your
candies go to stamps.com if you're sick
of going to the post office I'm not
saying you got to do it but if you're
sick going down there standing in those
long lines dealing with those grumpy ass
people you just want to print out your
stamps on your own go to stamps calm
once again enter the the code name BRR
Jesus Christ this is so much [ __ ] for a
[ __ ] like me to [ __ ] remember yeah
at the top of the home page type in
Burpee you are are on stamps comm and
amazon.com if you want to buy anything
not saying you got to none of this you
don't do any of these [ __ ] people so
there's no hard sell here if you want to
do it do it if you don't I don't give a
[ __ ] you know I'm gonna be here next
week you know I am that's it that's the
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourself
let's go Pat's
let's go Pat's bye after I ate ima I
gotta admit giant said like the one New
York team that doesn't bug me I don't
mind the Rangers either I don't mind the
Rangers I don't really even mind the
Knicks either I just don't like New York
fans that's just what it is you know III
you know it is I'm jealous that they
have the Yankees and all those
championships because the Yankees with
all those championships have been able
to cover for the not even like from the
mediocre all the way down to absolute
[ __ ] franchises that they have they have
five other teams that absolutely [ __ ]
suck and if you're sick and listen to me
trash Boston I mean trash New York if
you want to see it hear something
hilarious Artie Lange did this [ __ ]
hilarious song you know that's stupid
New York song that that Empire State of
Mind New York right he did it for like
let's hear it for Boston and just [ __ ]
trashes Boston and it's at
hilarious and everything he's saying is
hilarious now now it's funny because
we've won all these championships and
that's the best part of the song is
listening to him dance around the fact
that we've won seven titles and we ran
the table so Bucky Dent and all that
shit's funny to me now I don't give a
[ __ ] but just some of his we made a
references a reference to stitches
comedy club stitches comedy club that
went out of [ __ ] business in 1993 I
know because I did the last weekend
they're [ __ ] hilarious oh when I'm
doing it might as well give a shout out
Nick DiPaolo in Artie Lange - the
funniest [ __ ] comedians I've ever
seen do their own sports show I don't
know the name of it but just google and
search them and check out their show and
that's it that's a podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll talk to you next week
you